après la débâcle du retrait des troupes
américaines en afghanistan l'heure est
aux explications
sur votre juste qu'on succès à spa
belgique un succès logistique lancement
que lui mais un échec stratégique en 17
jours plus de 123 mille personnes ont
été évacuées du pays mais après vingt
ans de présence militaire américaine les
talibans ont repris le pouvoir sans
tirer le moindre coup de feu
pour la première fois le chef d'état
major mangly et le chef du commandement
central américain admettent qu'ils
auraient voulu maintenir 2500 soldats en
afghanistan pour éviter l'effondrement
de l'armée afghane
un avis que le président américain n'a
pas suivi en entrevue le 19 août dernier
il affirmé qu'il n'était pas au courant
de cette recommandation non
encore personne ne m'en informer
disait-il
le 15 ou les talibans reprennent kaboul
le 26 ou alors que les ressortissants
américains et afghans se évacué très
soldats américains sont tués lors d'un
attentat terroriste
giorgio absent pendant plus de six
heures les chefs du pentagone ont été
interrogés sur la façon dont ils ont
géré cette opération nez rouge pol
l'armée afghane s'est tout simplement
évaporée du le secrétaire à la défense
lawrence m nous avons été pris par
surprise
le retrait des conseillers militaires
américains d'afghanistan il ya trois ans
a contribué à cette débâcle souligne
général melli l'armée afghane n'a pas
tenu
les états unis n'étaient pas prêts à
s'enliser dans une guerre interminable
et puis le général midi a dû s'expliquer
sur ses conversations avec son homologue
chinois à la fin du mandat présidentiel
de donald chante
les deux apple était pour répondre aux
inquiétudes des chinois dit-il qui
craignaient une attaque des hits et amis
je leur ai dit que le président est
champion n'avait pas cette attention
un échec donc stratégique admettent les
généraux en ce qui a trait à
l'afghanistan et le risque d'une
reconstitution d'al qaîda et de l'armée
islamique est bien réel sont heureux
bref c'est un retour à la case départ
ici à ces bois de l'eger glissera du
canada à washington